Viens me rencontrer ainsi que toute l'équipe de la série le lundi 18 septembre à Paris
pour la projection en avant-première de la fin de l’Épopée Temporelle dans une salle de cinéma exceptionnelle
Il va y avoir des questions-réponses, des surprises, le lien dans la description pour prendre ton billet. A lundi et tout de suite l'épisode 9
*musique* A travers les époques les dangers, une grande aventure les appelle c'est c'est c'est L'EPOPEE TEMPORELLE !
Nos héros sont en plein tournoi dans le Japon féodal de 1150
S'ils gagnent, ils pourront récupérer la 3e relique du docteur Simon ce qui leur permettra enfin de le retrouver
Malheureusement, le pirate "la buse" et Elliot le robot ont été éliminés.
Et tout le poids de la mission se retrouve sur les épaules frêles de Thomas.
Parce que oui, Thomas est toujours dans l'aventure!
C'est fou non ?
Thomas: Attendez,
Thomas : C'est moi qui doit me battre contre le samouraï ?
Iris : Ah beh je l'aurai bien fait à ta place mais le règlement interdit les femmes de participer!
Thomas : Moi j'ai toujours été pour l'égalité homme-femme hein...
surtout si ça peut m'éviter de mourir sur un ring...
La buse : C'est ma faute les desamis.
J'ai perdu à un combat et ça m'était jamais arrivé ! Pendant toute ma vie j'ai gagné, 17 ans de victoires!
Iris : T'as 17 ans? Tu les fais pas du tout!
La buse : C'est parce que j'ai encore un œil valide, ça me rajeunit
Iris : Bon de toute façon on pouvait pas prévoir tout ça. Ce n'est pas de votre faute si...
Qu'est-ce qui lui arrive à l'autre là ? Ca va Eliot ?
Eliot : Snif...
Iris : Pourquoi il a dit "snif" ?
Il beug ou quoi ?
La buse : Je crois que notre frère de métal est en train de pleurer
T'inquiète pas, ça m'est arrivé aussi... UNE fois
à ma naissance mais le répétez pas hein !?
Iris : Non mais Eliot ne peut pas pleurer c'est une machine à café
Eliot : Techniquement je ne peux pas pleurer mais je suis quand même triste Iris
Voix robotique : *Snif supplémentaire*
Iris : Mais t'es triste de quoi ? De plus avoir de touillettes en stock ? *rires*
C'est drôle, non ?
La buse : T'es dure Iris...
Eliot : Je suis triste parce que c'est de ma faute si on ne retrouvera jamais le docteur Simon et que Thomas va mourir
Thomas : QUOI !?
Eliot : Mais ça, ça va, j'arrive à gérer
Thomas : Ah donc en fait je vais mourir ...
Eliot : Quand je suis arrivé dans votre famille Iris, j'ai tout de suite compris où était ma place
Dans la cuisine ... entre Gérard et Murielle
Iris : Euuuuh qui sont ?
Eliot : Le frigo et le lave-vaisselle
Il faut s'intéresser au petit personnel Iris
Iris : Oulala, pardon
Thomas : Et si on revenait sur le fait que je vais mourir moi ça m'intéresse ...
Eliot : le professeur Simon a toujours été gentil avec moi, il est le père que j'ai toujours voulu avoir
alors que toi Iris, sa vraie fille, tu ne voulais pas de lui. C'est triste non ?
Thomas : Boooh pas aussi triste que ma mort imminente...
Eliot : Quand il a disparu et qu'il m'a appelé, je me suis dit ça y est, c'est mon heure de gloire
je vais le retrouver et il me dira :
Voix robotique : merci fiston
La buse : Op ça y est, je pleure... Me regardez pas ou j'vous tue !
Iris : Je suis désolé Eliot, je savais pas
Thomas : Personne est désolé de savoir que je vais mourir par contre
Iris : Bon écoutez moi ! Personne ne va mourir et on va gagner ce tournoi ok ?
Et puis on va récupérer la dernière relique et retrouver mon père
Et ça c'est grâce à toi Eliot, parce que t'es pas qu'un robot. Maintenant t'es un...
La buse : Un DESAMI !
Iris : VOILA ! Un desami
Eliot : Merci...
Voix Robotique : Fin du mode "Tristesse".
Début du mode "Reprise de confiance en soi"
Thomas : Ah ! Je suis content d'apprendre que je vais pas mourir
Et j'ai hâte de savoir comment c'est possible, du coup
Iris : Thomas! Si tu utilises ta force face à ce samouraï, tu vas mourir
Thomas : Ok ...C'est pas du tout ce que je voulais entendre ...
Iris : La seule façon pour toi de gagner le match,
c'est de pousser le samouraï hors du ring, ok ?
Thomas : Je sais faire ça moi ... ?
Iris : C'est pour ça qu'il faut que tu t'entraînes, euh genre beaucoup...
Thomas : Le match est dans 5 minutes !
Alors oui j'apprends vite, j'ai fini sniper élite 4 sans les tutos mais quand même...
Eliot : On peut voyager dans le temps je vous rappelle. On peut passer des heures à s'entraîner où on veut et quand on veut
Iris : Ok ! Donc la question c'est où et quand apprendre à pousser quelqu'un très fort ?
Thomas : Quelqu'un de dos ça m'arrangerait...
Iris : Quelqu'un qui mérite qu'on le pousse des centaines de fois sans ressentir de culpabilité ...
Hitler : Je vais ouvrir un peu plus grand pour moiii...
Iris : Bon tu as vu comment j'ai fait Thomas ? à toi maintenant !
Eliot, on recommence !
Vas-y Thomas !
Thomas : OK, j'y vais!
Thomas: Oh non ! J'ai ripé, il est pas tombé
Hitler : Vous avez essayé de ME POUSSER NEIN !?
ce n'est pas très gentil tout ça
Iris : Finis le, Thomas !
La buse : Je le fais !
Hitler : Mais qu'est-ce que vous fAAAA...
La buse : aaaaaah, quelle sensation agréable
Iris : Ah ouais c'est cool hein de pousser Hitler d'un balcon
La buse : C'est qui Hitler ?
Iris : Bah c'est... Ah ben oui c'est vrai, tu peux pas le connaître
La buse : C'est la première fois que je voyais ce petit bonhomme !
Thomas : Et tu l'as poussé comme ça, sans savoir pourquoi ?
La buse : Moi quand je vois quelqu'un près d'une fenêtre je le pousse, c'est dans ma nature
Iris: Ah! Bon bah on va éviter de s'approcher trop près du bord alors.
Eliot, on repart en arrière.
Thomas soit ferme sur tes appuis.
Allez! Vas-y Thomas
Thomas: Ok!
Iris: Super Thomas! Yes!
Thomas : Merci
Iris: Allez, on y retourne!
Iris: Bien en appui sur le pied gauche
Thomas : Ok
La Buse: C'est bien mon bonhomme
Iris: Plus rapide, plus rapide, Thomas!
Thomas: Ok, plus rapide!
Iris: 1 2 3, bien en appui...Go!
Iris: Ok, tu t'améliores Thomas. On y retourne. Eliot
La buse: Allez Thomas!
Thomas : Ok, j'y vais!
Hitler: Mais arrêteeeeeez!
Thomas: Eh mais c'est bizarre. Il a dit un truc nouveau là
Eliot: C'est impossible. Chaque fois qu'on remonte dans le temps la réalité redémarre
Iris: Allez, on y retourne!
Iris: Imagine que c'est un samouraï maintenant
(Hitler: Je vais ouvrir un peu plus grand la fenêtre)
Thomas: Ok! Au revoir le samouraï!
Hitler: Non mais ça suffiiiiiiiiiiit!
Thomas: Mais j'ai l'impression qu'il sait qu'on le pousse à chaque fois
Iris: C'est vraiment bizarre. On recommence! Thomas, tu dois être prêt!
Thomas: Ok!
Thomas: Eh bah ça alors!
Thomas: Il n'est plus là!
Eliot: C'est anormal.
Thomas : Il... Il est où?
Eliot: Hitler a disparu de la pièce
La buse: Où tu te caches petit bonhomme à moustache?
Iris: Bon, on n'a plus personne à pousser...
Iris: Fin de l'entraînement
Iris: Eliot, on retourne à notre tournoi
Thomas: Ok... Je pense que je me sens prêt
Thomas: Je peux le pousser
Commentateur: Eeeet, c'est parti pour la finale!
Commentateur: Takeshi, le grand samouraï
et la fierté de la nation
contre Thomas
Commentateur: Juste euh... Thomas...
Commentateur: Les adversaires se saluent et...
Que le meilleur gagne!
Thomas: Ok je suis prêt!
Iris: Vas-y Thomas!
Thomas: Je vais le faire!
La Buse: Pousse-le Thomas!
Thomas: J'y vais!
*Bruits de pas*
Thomas: Eeeeh yah!!
*Bruit sourd*
Public: Ouuuuuuuh!!
Thomas: Aïe!
La Buse: Il aurait dû pousser son adversaire non?
La Buse: Pas seulement rebondir contre lui
Eliot: Contrairement à Hitler, le samouraï est très lourd
Eliot: 90 kg de muscles, plus une armure
Eliot: C'est plus dur du coup!
Iris: Oh tu m'étonnes...
Iris: Le samouraï n'a même pas bougé.
Thomas: Aïe! Avec son armure, il m'a super fait mal aux mains!
Thomas: Regardez c'est tout rouge!
Commentateur: La charge de Thomas n'a pas suffi.
Commentateur: Et maintenant, c'est Takeshi qui sort lentement son katana
Commentateur: Il s'approche de Thomas qui est figé de peur
Thomas: Me tuez pas!
Iris: Thomas!!
Thomas: *pleurs* Non non non non!!
Commentateur: Mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait?
Commentateur: Il semblerait que Thomas se recroqueville par terre et sur le côté
Iris: Thomas, relève-toi!
Commentateur: Thomas est en position fœtale...
Commentateur: Il avance sa main près de son visage...!
(Thomas: Je ne veux pas mourir...)
Commentateur: Il sort son pouce...
Commentateur: Et il... Et il... Eh oui!
Commentateur: Il le met à sa bouche pour le téter!
Commentateur: Oh mon Dieu!
Commentateur: Mais qu'est-ce que je vois là... Non...
Commentateur: Mais si...
Commentateur: C'est bien de l'urine qui coule de son pantalon!
Commentateur: Vous allez peut-être bien la goûter celle-là, non?
Commentateur: Ah ça va avec cette histoire!
Iris: Oh merde... C'est trop triste
Eliot: Et terriblement gênant
Eliot: Je propose qu'on ne dise pas à sa mère comment il est mort
Eliot: On dira qu'il est tombé d'une falaise en jouant à *voix différente* Pokémon Go
Eliot: C'est plus noble!
La Buse: Adieu petit matelot chétif et imberbe
Commentateur: Que se passe-t-il?
Commentateur: Takeshi le grand samouraï est figé...
Commentateur: Son katana à la main
Commentateur: Il ne donne pas le coup de grâce
Commentateur: Oh, attendez attendez!
Commentateur: Je crois qu'il va dire quelque chose
Takeshi: Ce n'est pas un combattant...
Takeshi: C'est un enfant!
Takeshi: J'ai déshonoré mon clan en me battant contre lui!
Takeshi: Je ne mérite pas de vivre!
Commentateur: Oulala!
Commentateur: Takeshi retourne la lame contre lui!
*bruit de lame*
Public: Oooooh!
Commentateur: Takeshi sort le hara-kiri
Commentateur: Ces boyaux tombent au sol
Commentateur: Takeshi s'effondre
Commentateur: Il est mort!
Iris: Attendez! Quoi?!
Commentateur: Une défaite par hara-kiri
Commentateur: comme on n'en a euh...
Commentateur: déjà vu n'est-ce pas?
Commentateur: Mais tout à fait!
Commentateur: C'est vrai que dans notre pays, on ne se suicide pas avec le dos de la cuillère
Commentateur: Eeeet Thomas remporte la relique ancestrale
confiée par le grand esprit
(Iris: Oh yes!)
au manteau aussi blanc que la cime du mont Fuji
(Iris: On a gagné!)
Commentateur: Ainsi qu'un magnifique porte-clé en bronze
Commentateur: Sauf s'il veut également se suicider pour laver son honneur d'avoir gagné d'une manière aussi honteuse
Thomas: Euh... non non! Je préfère gagner!
Commentateur: Alors... On applaudit...
le gagnant du tournoi! *applaudissements*
Thomas: *rire nerveux* Yes!
La Buse: Bravo! J'ai pas compris comment tu as fait mais tu l'as fait!
Thomas: J'ai utilisé la pression psychologique
Thomas: Je suis pas seulement un physique vous savez
Thomas: Je suis aussi un fin stratège
Iris: Donc c'était une ruse, c'est ça?
Thomas: Mais évidemment...
Thomas: C'était pour de faux
Iris: Bah ça sent le vrai pipi dans ton pantalon
Thomas: Ah bah désolé je voulais que ce soit crédible alors oui!
Thomas: J'ai utilisé mon urine pour faire transparaître la peur
Thomas: ça s'appelle l'acting madame
Eliot: Le plus important est qu'il est gagné
Iris: Ouais ouais...
Iris: Bon! Allons retrouver le shōgun pour récupérer la relique
*Musique de transition*
Shōgun: Étrangers, vous avez gagné le grand tournoi avec courage
Shōgun: Non, je ne peux pas dire ça...
Shōgun: Vous avez gagné quoi...
Shōgun: Tenez, la relique
Thomas: Ah oui? C'est plus la relique ancestrale confiée....
Shōgun: Ça va! Prenez ce truc et cassez-vous de mon palais hein!
Shōgun: Et changez votre pantalon de grâce!!
Shōgun: Ça sent jusqu'ici!!
Iris: Merci
Iris: Eh mais... Mais la relique c'est...
Shōgun: Une dague de petite taille mais d'une incroyable finesse, oui
Eliot: C'est le couteau de la cuisine
Eliot: Je le reconnais. Le docteur Simon l'utilisait pour couper les légumes
Thomas: Et il s'appelle comment ce couteau? Raymond? Fabrice?
Eliot: C'est un couteau Thomas
Eliot: Les objets n'ont pas de prénom
Iris: Non mais c'est pas que ça!
Iris: C'est le couteau que je lui ai offert pour la fête des pères quand j'avais 10 ans
La Buse: Ah!
La Buse: A 10 ans, j'étais encore avec ma première femme moi
Iris: Non mais la première relique, c'était un cadeau de mon père
Iris: La deuxième aussi! Et celle-là, c'est un cadeau que j'ai fait à mon père! C'est pas un hasard!
Thomas: Tu es sûre c'est pas juste des objets qu'il a pris au hasard chez lui
Iris: Mais non! Ça veut dire qu'il essaie de me faire passer un message
Iris: Ça veut dire qu'il pense à moi...
Iris: Et qu'il compte sur moi pour le retrouver
Eliot: Oui! Enfin... je te rappelle qu'il m'a appelé moi à la base
Eliot: comme un père qui demande de l'aide à son fils
Iris: Oui! Et tu es venu me retrouver après
Iris: Il savait que tu allais faire ça et que j'allais retrouver ces reliques
Thomas: Ah! Et il savait pour moi aussi?
Iris: Ah non... non non, il ne savait pas pour toi... Tu es un accident de parcours toi
Thomas: Merci... Ca fait toujours plaisir!
Shōgun: Vous êtes toujours dans mon palais là
Iris: Ah oui pardon! Eliot, qu'est-ce qu'on fait?
Eliot: Je fusionne les coordonnées des reliques
Eliot: C'est bon! J'ai décodé de nouvelles coordonnées temporelles
Eliot: Oh!
Thomas: Qu'est-ce qu'il y a?
Iris: On va où?
Eliot: Cette époque et ce lieu ne vont pas vous plaire
Eliot: Retemporalisation immédiate
Alala! Mais où nos héros vont-ils encore atterrir?
Et que va-t-il leur arriver?
Pour le savoir, il va falloir acheter le dernier épisode pour la modique somme de 99 euros!
Hein? Pardon? *rires*
Il sera gratuit comme les autres
C'est une bonne nouvelle!
Rendez-vous pour la fin de l’Épopée Temporelle!
Merci d'avoir écouté l'avant-dernier épisode de l’Épopée Temporelle saison 1!
N'hésite pas à t'abonner et à mettre un pouce en l'air.
Et à la semaine prochaine pour la fin de la saison #Jambon